hey guys happy tech tuesday i'm really
excited for you guys to witness this
episode because i got something very
exciting in the mail to test out for you
guys today but somehow i have to get
this said large item from the downstairs
up the steps into my office
all right let's begin the process for
those of you who may be wondering what i
am going to bring up at pax prime this
year intel announced their new fourth
generation core i7 processor extreme
edition it's intel's first 8 core 16
thread processor ddr4 memory support
and you my friends are about to witness
the unboxing of said
not processor we're unboxing the entire
computer with a processor in it and
there it is oh my gosh how am i gonna
get you
up here
all right it's time to take this thing
up the stairs it's so massive
oh my gosh this i i really think this
might weigh more than me
okay all right
holy crap
a lot of my dog i need friends
okay if i could just slide it
up
this
oh my god
this is working out nicely
but
my quads are burning
i just gotta
do this a little bit of
this okay
i'm stuck on something
we got this we got this we got this
we got this
oh my gosh
only a few more steps to go i gotta get
under it i just gotta get under it
oh god
we're on land
good girl
all right we got the box now it's time
to open this thing up
scissors and knives oh my
first cut is the deep
we've got a problem
this side up
which side
is up
oh
we're inside
we've got our power cable
looks like some things hook up my
graphics card it's the big unveiling
please don't fall on me
it's definitely upside down
oh gosh i'm moving oh we're on the move
this might come as a surprise to some of
you but i actually uh used to build pcs
i'm not very good at it but the fact
that i tried and that i have built a pc
in the past actually a couple of them
uh i'm i'm very proud i'm very proud i
don't think i would attempt that now
i love that this is on like this little
hinge
i'm sorry i'm just looking
looks great
all right we finally have internet i had
to run
ethernet all the way up around my
apartment into
a big circle i'm about to download steam
get some games let me know what you guys
think that i should play i think i'm
going to download alien isolation and
i'll be playing that on my gaming
channel and if i don't decide to play
that let me know what you guys would
like to see me play i'll be posting some
gaming stuff in the next couple of weeks
so that's it thank you guys for watching
let me know
uh i don't know just tell me a story in
the comments i love you guys i'll see
you soon i'm gonna go play some games
now